this is a production of Cornell
University well good afternoon folks are
you can tell them probably not a member
of sips
my name is a pulse although I am part of
all biomedical sciences and it's really
my privilege to introduce today's
speaker Joe Ecker Joe did his
undergraduate at Rutgers he does PhD at
Penn State in postdoc at Stanford he was
a Penn faculty member before moving out
to the saw queries in HM HHMI
investigator so I went through his CV
there really too many honors and awards
to list I'll mention just a couple of
them member of the National Academy of
Sciences fellow of triple-a s member of
the American Academy of Arts and
Sciences he's won some notable awards
including the beetle award from the
Genetics Society of America and the
Gibbs medal from the American Society of
thought plant biology we have at least
one Award winner as well in the audience
is gene Ostrovsky tanks it was an award
member and also make a plug for an
upcoming seminar by Craig Picard who's
also a receive nd of that award so
that'll be on um well I guess April 16th
so hopefully we'll see you again for
that a wonderful talk there's so many
things that really characterize Joe's
career and I'll just try to distill down
a couple of them there he's really had
some pioneering work in genomic
structure and this really extends you
back to his graduate days when he was
characterising viral isomers of eres
Ella's austere and detecting them in
human tissue these were notable changes
or things that had not been recognized
in viral genomes he got very interested
and also further genomic manipulations
as a postdoc and on Davis's lab at
Stanford developing some tools for
inhibiting RNA processing or rather RNA
expression patterns and plants using
antisense he developed our methods for
cloning large pieces of DNA and yeast
artificial chromosomes from Arabidopsis
they're really seminal events and really
being able to sequence the arab Dobson's
genome and of course he developed many
different available widely available
mutants in the arab adopts this genome
that a number of you are have used and
will continue to use again really big
impacts on on these fields now he also
very interesting underlying mechanisms
of gene regulation and plant development
and and in work that he began around
Davis's lab that is continuing now
really focuses on on mechanisms of
signal transduction and how ethylene is
regulating fundamental processes in
plants and of course other hormones as
well and that might be something that a
lot of you will follow now working at at
at the Salk he's in the midst of a bunch
of neuro scientists and accordingly he's
gotten very interested and some of the
opportunities that neuroscience has has
that can apply methods that he's
developed and one of the things that I
should also add is that although I'm not
a plant biologist I became very aware of
some of the work that Joe was done in
plants when he really reported the very
first methylome from the rabbit OPS's
initially using microarray approaches
and then later on the very first single
nucleotide methalone from Arabidopsis
was produced up i work that he did with
steve jacobson and because sequencing
technology is so robust he was able to
expand that to the mammalian genome and
that's and that's what he has done more
the single-cell methods that he's using
really provides enormous resolution for
what we know about tissue structure and
tissue regulation I'm gonna keep quiet
now and I'll just ask Joe to wow us with
the science thank you Paul for this
great kind introduction and I guess and
when Adam invited me I didn't quite
realize that this was a talk in that
school of plant sciences but I will
actually talk about a little bit in the
beginning about how I got into this you
know neuro stuff but I'll sort of store
it and the kind of more fundamental
things that we're interested in which is
really these are the systems that we use
so you actually doesn't look too
different or app adopts us in right
neuron so there's some similarity here
it's easy to get by in the lab are you
studying this or this so what I want to
talk about today actually I will briefly
talk about some studies just to kind of
tell you what we've been doing the last
few years and rapid offices in terms of
epigenetics
what links these together interested our
interest in reprogramming and epigenomic
diversity and in cells and and
populations of cells and populations of
plants and how these epigenetic marks
changed during development and then I'll
analysis or switched or sort of nura at
the genomics approach so that sort of
theme is and I'm sure that you're all
equally interested many of you in the
same thing which is how you go from one
genome to many cell types and how much
of that is hardwired I mean to get cell
types that are reproducible there has to
be a heritability component to this
there's also things that go awry in
development through genetic mutation and
let and likely due to epigenetic
variation as well and just organize the
keystone meeting called the 3d genome
with being ran in and and a Pombo and
Brad Bernstein was talking about some
epi alleles that happen in cancer there
are really truly up your lilz that
there's no genetic variants detectable
and so how you go from here to here
every cell I used to say I'd and I
identical genome that's not true there's
a lot of somatic variation that happens
mutation structural variation
transposition etc most of that I believe
is probably destructive in terms of the
function not instructive in the genome
but nevertheless it happens work from
Chris Walsh and rusty Gage and others
it's quite interesting looking at
lineages by following mutations through
development but there's obviously
additional information needed to read
out to create this diversity and so then
you have the rapid OPS's version here
with equally beautiful cell types that
were also interested in from the five
chromosomes so we so defining usually
there's some onus on the speaker if
you're talking about epigenetics
especially with Eric Richards in the
audience to define what you mean by an
epigenetics day and I and so I I don't
have my own definition I adopt this
definition which I like very much by
Adrian Berg
virtual adaptation of chromosomal
regions has to register signal or
perpetuate an altered activity state
there's some component of heritability
of things like DNA methylation that that
that kind of ring true for me in this
statement so you know accessibility to
the genome is is the is the issue here
and sort of transcription factors being
able to access chromatin modifying
chromatin modified chromatin proteins
being able to bind and inhibit proteins
transcription factors from binding DNA
methylation attracting and inhibiting
proteins from binding to the genome and
so genome access is a sort of feature
here we're particularly and so these are
some of the roles here that sort of been
I would say from the very beginning you
know one of the earliest features of
trying to understand the epigenome is
the regulation of transposons silencing
it's been somewhat challenging to for
some of these other topics to really
kind of get to mechanism one of the
things that we're interested in is and
kind of driving a lot of these studies
is to understand the role of a single
modification let's say this modification
cytosine to adding a methyl group in
five position is the whether or not that
impacts directly on transcription
factors interacting with the genome or
not in the motif there are a number of
labs I'll mention that have been working
on this and I can I'll briefly mention
some of our studies in this area so sort
of step one for us was try to understand
where these modifications are occurring
and what time in the development of the
organism a reprogramming or they're
occurring to be able to then begin to
ask the question of whether there was
any impact
so as these surveys based on sequencing
as Paul mentioned and so few years ago
plant biologists in the lab Ryan Lister
who is his own group in Perth developed
this asset which we call methyl see seek
and in parallel Steve Jacobson we had
been working together on array based
approaches and they've kind of diverged
and started developing our own method
separately and Steve also had a paper
very almost like the same month or so
which was very nice and using a
different method so essentially this is
the old Kim this is an old chemistry
from the 70s that then sue Clark and her
colleagues adapted for sequencing which
is to treat cytosine with high
temperature and sodium bisulfite which
you get at deamination reaction you end
up cytosine to uracil which when you
copy that results in a c to t change in
the DNA sequence and so that's simply we
just coupled that assay to sharing and
making a genomic library adapting it
with methylated adapters so that they
wouldn't change their sequence and then
using the actually the very first alexa
machine one of the machine number eleven
i think we had to be able to do this so
that required some challenges of
developing tools for being able to to to
map reads i won't go through the details
of this is published a long time ago
quantify cytosine at these various
positions and so cg so the context of
methylation for some of the enzymes that
methyl a DNA is to methylate c sitting
next to g on the same strand and so
that's a symmetrical event where you
have methylation on the after
replication on the opposite strand of cg
but there's also a symmetrical
methylation which actually is well known
in arab analysis was really unknown in
the mammalian genome OCA which has no
counterpart of cytosine on the opposite
strands of asymmetric so it can be this
context can change it can be see acc AG
depending on the developmental stage and
that information then could be used to
to build so we call these single
methylation events single methylation
polymorphisms or smith's sort of
equivalent to snips where you have
methylation variation at one position
the variation comes from the fact that
well you either have two two two two
alleles you have you know 50%
methylation 0 or 100 but when you have a
complex tissue that where you have cells
having different methylation profiles it
turns out that you
have a range right anywhere from you
know no methylation to 100% throughout
that whole range so the so-called
partially methylated domains lowly
methylated amazed and typically what
investigators do is to is to cluster
these together into larger regions which
we call differentially methylated
regions or dmrs
and these just happen to be what we're
looking at here is a segment of DNA
where each gold tick here is a
methylated cytosine in a cg context and
these happen to be you know this is a
small portion of the you know of a
embryonic stem cell genome and and and
what we're looking at here either real
embryonic cells or induced pluripotent
stem cells and you can easily spot this
difference in every single every
pluripotent stem cell you've ever looked
at has features in the genome that have
resulted from the inability to be
reprogrammed by a for transcription
factors that now Menaka won the Nobel
Prize for 99.9 percent of the genome is
amazingly reprogrammed with those
factors but there are certain regions of
the genome that are resistant to
reprogram and they can be they actually
have a histone modification that's
preventing the that the factors were
prevented from reprogramming the
Associated methylation that information
can be associated with other kinds of
histone modification open chromatin etc
transcription factor binding assays to
create maps of the of the epigenome if
you will and so we've worked on a rapid
OPS's sort of profiling of various
states and this just shows some
summaries of some of the things that
we've been interested in and we continue
to be interested in but as you'll see it
it's through a different level of
resolution so we've we've worked on with
Phillip Phillip mp's lab on profiling
cell profiles of the root for example
epidermis cortex and the dermis etc were
Phil's done fact sorting of protoplasts
and then we've profiled the methyl ohms
for example to transcriptomes
of also the NIR small RNA profiles of
different sources and we can I
identify lineage sort of cell lineage
specific DNA methylation events we can
also identify regions that were
responsive to either biotic stress or
pathogen response again this is treating
the whole leaf for example with the
pathogen and then doing home you know
essentially if you have a million cells
you're profiling a million methyl arms
in the same tube right so it's amazing
that you can see any differences here at
all and you'll see from some of them
neuron studies I'll show you that our
eyes were open when we started to switch
to to higher resolution methods or a
collaboration so we've had a look at
nutrient changes vibration with O'Brien
Lister's lab in in in in routes for
example phosphate stress where you have
even have heritable a change that I
heritable for very long heritable let's
say for a generation or two but those
methylation of methylation differences
can be can be inherited for a short
period of time we've also looked at sort
of generational heritance of methyl ish
and this is work from Bob Schmidt's who
I hear is coming for a seminar in a few
weeks and Bob will tell you all about
this I just wanted to point out that you
can use a rapid OPS's use these mutation
accumulation lines that Raja had
developed over 30 generations and Bob
profile you know individual cytosine
methylation over these we call these
sort of ancestors and then descendants
of those looking at individual
methylation variation over time you can
see that some individuals lose this cg
methylation at this one particular
position in replicates here so they've
lost it somewhere along the line and I
think Bob has looked at more carefully
now where where that where this is lost
what the frequency isn't Elif Weigel's
lab actually has done some work very
similar work like this and so you know
the ancestors are more similar to one
another in the methylome and the
descendants are similar to one another
but they're different from one another
in fact the difference is very large
there there's five orders of magnitude
if you compared sort of genetic
accumulation mutant mutation with these
kinds of events which we're not
what the meaning is but certainly their
heritable events the there's about five
orders of magnitude difference but if
you if you look at more striking events
like this where you have a gene that's
not only methylated in the cg context
but matt has this non CG asymmetric
methylation which is indicative of what
a rapid axis recognizes as trans bosons
by an RNA directed DNA methylation
system these kinds of events typically
are associated with silencing so if you
look at at the mRNA levels of these
corresponds here into the individual one
individual 19 individual and then these
are the descendants some of the
descendants here descend number 59 in
replicates has lost this methylation and
you can see this log to scale here so
there's a hundredfold or so increase of
transcription of this gene so perfectly
good gene okay as far as we know that
has been silenced in this genetic
background Columbia 0 the wild-type that
$70,000,000 sequence genome is now
released from silencing okay so and then
the the the genes the were silenced were
associated with small rnas and those
small rnas disappear in this so you have
a flip of this so-called epi olio
l'amanda you can measure you can measure
the frequency the frequency of this
happening is about the mutation
frequency in the genome very similar
that the fraggles lab sequenced actually
all of these lines to determine the
mutation frequency and this frequency of
sort of gene activation from silencing
is about the same as mutation frequency
so that looked interesting so we expand
to this to then look at thousands of
Abba dabbas of genomes and so we we have
a a kind of a resequencing project that
involved many labs particularly the
lives of Magnus norburg and telev why go
involved with in Monsanto Company todd
todd michael in monsanto sequenced 500
accessions over RepA DOCSIS and we did
my lab transcriptomes for those and DNA
methyl ohm sequencing and this was kind
of intersect of those and this just
shows some of that you know a snapshot
of just some of those so we're able to
so
monitor these events Magnus lab has
become particularly interested in
associating this kind of epigenetic
variation whether there's you know more
more methylation or less methylation and
associating that with sort of
temperature and precipitation gradients
and one thing we found that was quite
interesting was is that some of the
absolute methylation levels of these
accessions were actually genetically
driven at least by these genome-wide
Association studies so these are the
five rapid of scores ohms if you use
methylation as a phenotype and you ask
are there low side that are segregating
that is the in this genome-wide
Association study that are linked to the
propensity to have more or less
methylation you identify genes that are
well-known in methylation pathway or the
rnase directed DNA methylation pathway
where the enzymes themselves that are
like maintenance methyl transferase met
one that have variants that these
haven't been proven but Magnus's lab is
working on this but I think the most
striking finding for me out of this was
that that if you if you look at any Arab
adopters gene you can say it can either
be unmethylated and completely
methylated
I think Bob will talk about body
methylation when he comes so this CG
methylation here which is mildly
associated with gene expression
differences and this kind of methylation
which is associated mostly with
silencing of the gene that if you take
across all the rapid OPS's genes across
the thousand and one accessions and you
look at their math lumps about 25% okay
seventh over seven thousand five hundred
genes can exist like this the Columbia
gene is silenced this this this
accession is sounds and the others are
not so you can have in the population
25% of all genes that could be a
perfectly good gene but they're silenced
and they can potentially flip back just
like we saw in Columbia some of these
may be associated with transposon
insertions etc but I think there's quite
a few of them that are very likely to be
a gene that is somehow triggered to have
been silenced that could potentially be
relieved from sounds and be expressed
and potentially be selected for if it
had a phenotype so from those same lines
we were able to
to take the their DNA and then asked
whether or not transcription factors
will bind if the DNA is methylated or
unmethylated an assay we call DNA
affinity purification sequencing so we
take genomic DNA shear it up and take
affinity tag two transcription factors
and do this sort of in high throughput
we screened 1,700 rabid OPS's
transcription factors over two thousand
experiments and I and essentially
identified you know TF motifs were about
ten percent of the genome but we were
particularly interested in whether or
not they were methyl sensitive binding
and so to do that we sort of modified
the asset where we just take the library
that we made here which is native
genomic DNA which is hasn't been
amplified and where you have methylation
events that might affect binding and
just amplify the library so that we
remove dilute out with non methylated
cytosine so we get this amp tapped
library and then then we can compare
that to sort of genomic information from
real gypsy experiments so this is in
vitro but here's just an example so
here's a transcription factor at ABA ABA
is a plant hormone that is involved in
sort of one of the master regulars for
ABA signaling and the chip seek shows a
peak here but no peak here when you
strip the DNA and you do an in vitro
assay you see binding here and if you
test in vitro aid the ABI the ABA bi5
gene it's methylation sensitive and so
this is in vitro assay but comparing at
the in chip seek result in a methylated
region it looks like it's sensitive so
if you take and you ask from this set of
Peaks where we know these in vitro
transcription factors are binding you
ask how much real estate is that if
you're looking leaves just leaf tissue
right and they ask how many
transcription factor binding sites might
be occluded by this methylation those
potentially hundred seventy thousand of
this 2.5 million that could be
potentially regulated in that tissue
because if there's no methylation it
could be chromatin regulation but
there's no ability for methylation to
affect it so there's this potential
there and you can take and do this
across all transcription factors you do
the dab assay where we're looking at the
blue here is the the lack of binding in
these families okay so 70 some percent
of the transcription factors show in
effect four percent show they like to
buy so if you see orange here this you
know for mostly zinc finger family
members or TCP or other MIBs etc they
like to bind more and if there's a
depletion here this is a window of 400
bases there's a depletion in the binding
and that in that target we haven't
brought this right down to the motif but
if you then use amplified DNA you see
that is the row rather normalized so you
remove the methylation and and and the
transcription factor affinity is is
altered in those cases and so that's
just also displayed here this is the
gradient of all the transcription
factors that you'd like to bind
methylated in a or how they're there
they're there anything close to here
would be unaffected and anything that
would be affected would be really
affected would be here when you remove
the methylation is sort of normalizes
that we didn't do it in a competitive
way we these were done in parallel
experiments so that's a caveat but if
you do it in competitor labs have done
it from a mouse transcript human and
mouse transcription factors in a
competitive way they cease very similar
results so what are we doing now this is
kind of the end the plant part where
we're we're trying to do this and
capture both the epigenetic variation
that we in the methylation assay as well
as the genetic variation and what you
can see here is sort of a transcription
factor in this in vitro binding acid
where you see differences you see two
peaks in one accession you know maybe
some additional Peaks that are weaker
and so some of these could be snips some
of these could be methylation variants
etc and here's an example of two strains
and some methyl three strains and
methylation differences that you see and
we begin to associate those differences
with genes that are then maybe involved
in in for example temperature response
across these plants or
tolerance and so we're just beginning to
do that now and we're going to take this
to a different level we want to not just
grind up and look at the whole sort of
methylamine
fax sort so we're doing is using you
know as a model seedlings either lated
seedlings which we know a lot about
hormone response is to basically carry
out single-cell sorts of single nucleus
is what we do we don't use protoplasts
protoplasts are very different in size
the cell volume is very different in
plant depending on what tissue is and so
you have very big biases and what gets
faxed and so the nuclear are much more
uniform as we used to do single nuclear
RNA seek and single nuclear attack seek
and so we're we're gonna try to look at
both genetic and epigenetic variation on
certain responses particularly hormone
responses using these assays so when
it's sort of switched to two what we're
spending a lot of effort on so applying
some of these sorts of methods and
trying to understand epigenetic
variation mostly in the mouse and some
in the marmoset which is very good model
for behavior we have a marmoset colony
it's all and then the ultimate challenge
is to beat this beast here which has
massive numbers if you look at cerebral
cortex here and just looking at neurons
they're 777 here there's 16 billion
neurons in the cortex actually serve
elements like the is the winner here at
69 million neurons most of your neurons
are in the cerebellum so that's a
massive task as part of the NIH brain
initiative most groups are focused on
the mouse with 80 80 million neurons or
so so why do this there's a lot of
interest in understanding cell types
there's a project called the human cell
atlas and there's sort of the equivalent
of this and the brain initiative that
we're part of because it's called the
brain initiative cell census consortium
and so one if there's a couple of
reasons that we're interested in
potential of epigenetic variation have
an effect on disease but there's also
been an enormous effort to link genetic
variance to for example psyche
Patrick disorders and this just shows
sort of heritability of phenotypes like
anxiety attention deficit post-traumatic
stress bipolar disorder etc so there the
missing hair should be 100% here right
now it's for some of these missing
heritability could be absence of large
numbers necessary numbers to identify
all the genes that are involved all the
snips are involved or in fact it could
be that there are other environmental
epigenetic effects you know other sort
of things that happen during the
development of an individual that are
not necessarily directly easily linked
to snips and so this is the snip based
heritability here so I think so this is
just an example of some genome-wide
Association study from schizophrenia
which has the very largest number of
individuals that have been examined in
these this is a gene that popped out
that was published just a few years ago
very interesting kind of somewhat
controversial compliment involved in in
blood the response the complement system
of the blood is involved in in a major
blow sigh involved in the number one
loss I involved in the comes out of the
Jewish grade so
so our our our sort of hypothesis here
is that these that cell types the cell
type phenotype is going to be affected
by these individual snip so in other
words you have a snip that's associated
with the genetic disease and you say oh
it's enriched in the the this snip falls
out outside of coding regions and falls
in some regulatory region in the brain
that is if you grind up the brain and
look for open chromatin histone marks
indicative of regulatory elements you
find that they're enriched in brain but
brain has massive numbers of cell types
still account unknown this just shows
part of the cortex that we were working
on and these are the layers there's six
layers and these are inhibitory neurons
they have different different
electrophysiological properties they
have different neurotransmitter
properties and these are some of those
sort of morphologically defined cell
types in the brain and so our our
hypothesis is is that we could separate
these different cell types either by
their transcriptome or maybe even by
looking at epigenetic states and these
different cell types by profiling
individual epigenetics days and in in
the process either from normal brain
identify regulatory islands and
potentially from diseased brain identify
mr. dysregulation at some of these sites
so that's what we're working on it so if
you actually look at the catalogue this
is sort of well known if you look at the
catalog of genetic variants and the same
is true exactly if a rapid OPS's all
numbers are almost the same 95 percent
or so of the of the genetic variants do
not lie in coding regions okay they lie
in introns or intergenic regions etc and
so so most of the genetic variation
between the Uni is going to be outside
of our genes and so to to associate a
snip in a regulatory element with the
gene is a task that many groups are
interested in trying to understand gene
regulation basically and so this this
involves for exam
Association of enhancers and promoters
and a lot of interest in understanding
how these come together and the
mechanisms by which enhancers are
enrolled in transcriptional regulation
through for example looping here a
number of proteins been identified in
these complexes but understanding
epigenetic variants or understanding
genetic variants and their association
with these elements I think is one of
the goals of the project and so that can
be done by beginning to accumulate
information in a sort of cell
type-specific way and a few years ago we
had a collaboration with Jeremy Nathan's
lab to sort of reproduce the experiment
that we were doing with Phil Ben fee and
purifying populations of neurons
excitatory and several classes of
inhibitory part of albumin expressing or
VIP expressing inhibitory neurons and
then profiling those cell purified cell
populations so either looking at
different chromatin marks active
chromatin marks Isetta lated histones or
DNA methylation this is CG methylation
and then identifying regions that you
have their association of reduced
methylation or these DMR's we have hypo
methylation and for example active
chromatin mark so here would be an
example of the association of predict
and enhancer element by the fact that it
hasn't a particular class of histone
modifications h3k27 to settle and it
reduced in DNA methylation okay so you
can you can identify neuron type
specific at this level excitatory
inhibitory noise but you have to go
through purifying these populations
through genetic tricks where you've
tagged these cells in vivo and then
purify them and so I guess the idea here
is is that you know trying to understand
this this enormous pool of information
we have for genetic variation by
beginning to start from the bottom up by
identifying cell types their regulatory
sequences and then beginning to link
those and a developmental profile
because these things change these
differentially methylated regions change
over development and trying to associate
risk variants
by a kind of building up the regulatory
element code and then associating it
with genome-wide Association studies so
but along the way so there's a sort of a
geneticist point of view is that this is
you know linking genetic variation to
actually where the genetic variation may
have an effect but there could also be
epigenetic variation here for example
chromatin dysregulation and particularly
that call is caused by some reason or
DNA methylation variation so we don't
have evidence for that we're sort of
building maps for the wild-type brain
basically a mouse to find that but what
is know so there are interesting I mean
data that's why we kind of launched into
this in the first place
changes in DNA methylation or proteins
and bind to it like this mecp2 protein
which causes Rhett syndrome caused
learning and memory defects and are
associated with cognitive decline okay
so there are known very few but there
are some known proteins that could read
out DNA methylation in in mammalian
cells but also mutation so you can make
a knock out a triple knock out of a cell
line of an embryonic stem cell and it
grows just fine but if you try to make a
mouse out of that you can't okay we're
working real doffy ancien others so
mouth mice with postnatal also you can
knock these out after birth and they
have effects on excitatory neurons
learning and memory cognitive defects
but very little is known about when or
where these kinds of changes are
happening in methylation and so that's
where you sort of got into this
beginning to look at the patterns of DNA
methylation and chrome open chromatin
changes and then ultimately with the
idea that we want to try and understand
whether these effects have any causality
and there are intriguing kinds of papers
that pop up I'm not showing you the most
controversial house I'm just showing
showing you some recent ones one from
one of my colleagues rusty gauge where
he has this maternal care model it's
been actually a model that's been around
a long time where where the the the
amount of association of the mother with
the pups in terms of the grooming
behavior has an impact on whether you
get more or less
transposition of of the line one element
in the brain and that that there's some
associations of those ability to
transpose with a reduction of dnmt3a
which would be involved in the silencing
of these line lines so somewhat
controversial it happens but whether or
not there's a cause-effect relationship
between this and it's hard to hard to
get at Rusty's labs working on that and
there are other studies that are
somewhat more controversial they have
smaller effect sizes where you you have
it's sort of a mimic of viral infection
in utero and then those mice often have
will have statistically significant
behavioral defects and that you could
attribute that to some variation in
india' methylation again very little no
because we don't know much about the
normal brain okay so this word a+
project is to move from whole tissues
down to single cells to try and kind of
get the resolution that we're interested
in so we started out you know profiling
the cortex of the mouse brain and this
was published awhile ago so we just
separated neurons from non neurons
supporting glial cells of various types
and then we went to this sort of
enrichment approach that we carried out
with Jeremy Nathan's where we could use
a genetic trick to tag nuclei of various
sorts using an insertion of a protein
into the nuclear membrane that had a tag
that we could then purify these
different populations in a in a in a
controlled developmental way I using
Cree and then carry out these sort of
studies and then more recently I'll tell
you about our single-cell analysis that
and what the differences are here so
just back to the beginning what did we
see why were we interested so we did a
developmental profile of mouse and human
cortex very crudely I said looking at
grinding up the whole cortex and this is
just measuring the bulk amount of CG
methylation or this CH methylation and
so there are actually really dynamic
changes and what what part of the genome
gets methylated does a whole
of half-a-million predicted regulatory
elements that become demethylated and
then remesh elated as in adults and
there's a paper we have on the bio
archive that describes this in the mouse
brain but if you just measure the bulk
amount it doesn't dramatically change
okay over time but if you measure this
non-symmetric methylation it pretty much
starts at zero at earth and accumulates
in neurons mostly although it does
accumulate somewhat in glial cells but
mostly neurons actually to a higher
level in the human brain actually if
these are different scales here but
about eight percent of the of the
cytosines are methylated in a CA context
than your your neuron and about 5% or
cytosine methylated in the cg context
and all of this is happening to a very
critical period of development okay
where neurons are making connections
there's a lot of synaptogenesis going on
here and there's no cell division for
the most part except in the dentate
gyrus and they hit the campus wood and
but most of the brain is not dividing
here so you're you're accumulating
methylation in this during this critical
window and there's a lot of interesting
experiments that are that I don't have
time to talk about here where for
example there's a visual input can be
blocked in the mouse and you can then
look at development of visual cortex in
the absence of stimulus during this
critical period when things are getting
wired up so we we carried out this
purification that I mentioned with
Jeremy okay and so if you grind up the
whole cortex and this is the methylation
pattern that you see over two different
genes in the genome right here okay and
if you were to if you were to ask is
this is this change in gene expression
here that's we're looking at Col cortex
so here's the transcripts that are
coming and you say oh is there a change
in that is there any signature that you
can detect in the metal oh the answer is
no you can't see anything yeah
because the signal is actually coming
from one percent of the cells in the pv
or two percent of the cells in the VIP
when you look here the poly a so you're
doing it so there's a lot of controversy
about whether methylation affects gene
rushon the answer in neurons is it's a
hundred percent correlated okay when you
sequence the transcriptome and the
methylome from the same cell you can
correlate transcription with methylation
variation whether it's causative I have
no idea but it's perfectly correlated
okay but when you do these kinds of bulk
experiments you don't see really what
the signature is here you can see the
footprint in the CA methylation
essentially it's a footprint of the
transcription unit okay it's completely
prevented from presumably from dnmt3a
accessing that that part of the genome
and so you can begin to associate these
differentially methylated regions not
only in the transcribe unit but upstream
okay
turns out that if you look at DNA
methylation variation in the mouse and I
think we've looked at 20-some organs at
ten developmental stages this is the bio
archive 90% of the methylation variation
is 10 KB or more away from the promoter
so essentially nothing is happening at
promoter okay in terms of methylation
except in cancer it's actually it has a
big role that is there's hyper
methylation of many genes in the
promoter but just in terms of the out
relative amount of variation that you
see most of the variation is distal to
the promoter okay
so if you if you zoom in to these sort
of purified cell populations you can
find regions neuron type specific so
Peavey do you know pv hyper methylation
or hypo methylation VIP these were genes
that would be hypo methylated or hyper
methylated are very specific to those
classes and then a whole bunch that
don't very much and there's some
interesting Association of these changes
with gene expression and particularly on
long genes neurons have neuronal
specific genes are actually quite long
in their enriched so if you look at the
longest genes in the genome they they're
enriched in genes expressed in neurons
and so there's an interesting
relationship between gene expression and
silencing of long genes that I'll point
to just a few papers I have time to go
into the discussions but labs that have
studied like
Barracuda Zogby there Adrienne birds
have studied extensively mecp2 which
binds to cg methylation so that is the
known target and mecp2 is methyl binding
you know protein it actually binds to
nan cg methylation as good if not better
in a competition assay so until we've
spotted this nan cg methylation was
completely unknown and if you actually
compare the data from these labs they
were finding very different results when
you look at the knockout mouse as to
which genes are affected or not in a
knockout but if you focus on the genes
that have nan cg methylation you get a
very good correlation of the data
between labs so that that suggests that
you know mecp2 binding and addition to
cg to nan cg methylation which recruits
a repressor complex several different
River customer complexes to presumably
silenced those genes is is playing a
role in this in this process so we use
this a rapid Oxus sort of assay and have
applied at the human transcription
factors but also you see two poly and
more recently Gary Stormo did a very
beautiful comparative acid on a
relatively small number of transcription
factors but a very high quantitative
assay where he measured the in a
competitive way the ability of a
transcription factor to bind to
methylated or unmethylated motifs and
and found that there's there's the in
you sees what i've found that about
fifty percent of all the human
transcription factors that he tested
although the set was biased towards
homido doing proteins were affected in
their binding to their motifs by
methylation and so we wanted to get sort
of an even deeper view so we went to
develop we in this case is Cheung Wong
Luo one of the most fantastic postdocs
that's ever joined my lab technically
and and in every other aspect and he
developed this assay where we could we
don't have to sort nuclei but because
it's were still relatively expensive to
profile of the methylome we sequence
about a million reads per cell he uses
new end that is a neuron specific marker
and
sort of leave behind that cells that are
non non new and positive that actually
leaves some classes of neurons behind so
we're sort of as we ramp up here we're
including more we collect about 10% of
these cells and 90% of these cells so we
don't miss something and then we just
drop nuclei into wells and now we're
going to 1536 plates we could do easily
you know six thousand a week and we're
hoping doubts ramped at four times the
twenty five thousand a week to be able
to profile significant numbers of cells
because the brain is it's got an
enormous number of neurons we want to
get its sampling of all the brain
regions at least in the mouse and so the
key with with chang-jung is there are a
couple of other assays that wool freak
has a nice assay to measure individual
methyl ohms the difference is is that we
only do sort of a one round of
amplification we don't reprime it so we
have very high map ability rate because
we worked with Swift Biosciences when
they had developed a technology to
capture the end of the molecule so you
can prime and extend and then we need to
capture the end of the molecule and
that's a very inefficient process but
they have a very efficient process to
essentially tail the end of the molecule
so we can then we don't have to go
through multiple rounds of adding P PCR
and primers and then cycling which gives
you a lot of clone out of carnality
issues as well as chimera Creed's and
things so those are the technical
details what we do is we we basically we
can either bend the genome where we can
bin gene so either 100 KB bins were
actually genes and we we typically read
out greater than 250 cytosine
methylation events in the two and 100 KB
bin and that gives us about 22 if you
use rnase as genes here whether gencode
annotation so that's more than protein
coding genes non-coding RNA is etc
53,000 genes we can measure 22,000 in it
about half or so in in the assay by
scoring methylation across the genes of
the gene body
and so
take that data and then I don't have
time to go through this but we carry out
iterative clustering analysis in a in a
routine that allows us to to determine
so start with you know the classes that
I told you excited Tori inhibitory glia
etc this just shows motor cortex okay it
was part of the core decoded cortex that
then then those are further subdivided
based on iterative came K nearest
neighbor clustering and then feature
selection and then reakless Turing to
give you another set of layer specific
markers for example he was layer four or
five etc and then those clusters can be
further subdivided where we can say okay
what are the differences between these
four pv clusters and we could tell you
you know there's you know two thousand
differentially methylated regions or
genes etc that separate these in which
which they are so we can define what
those differences are so that down the
road we can say okay these four
potential regulatory elements that are
unique to those subtypes because our
goal here is to not only identify cell
types but to make genetic drivers to be
able to target these cells using
regulatory elements from these they're
unique to these subtypes okay so what
does that look like just a sort of just
a snapshot of you know here's 166 this
is from human brain now 166 layer two
three neurons that were identified and
this is a 450 KB window and each one of
these tracks are so yellow is is
depleted and methylation blue is
enriched and methylation so just getting
a snapshot of the the window across this
gene of the differential methylation in
these different cell clusters and this
is kind of the standard track view where
you've sort of averaged you've collapsed
all of this data and just make one
statement about what the methylation
pattern is whereas here we're looking at
the individual cells that we've profiled
to just give you an idea of what the
sort of raw data looks like so you need
statistics to see the difference that's
right you can see very big differences
in the
gene body methylation of this gene also
in the regulatory illness so what we did
to convince ourselves that there was
something interesting here is we
actually did layer dissections we said
we took a piece of a mouse quartz
actually used undigested we profiled you
know several hundred cells we did a
dissection of the superficial layer sort
of layer 1 2 and then 5 6 and then
everything in the middle again we
profiled these three so we knew true
what the truth was of where you came
from okay so this was the clusters that
were generated by actually an earlier
method that wasn't is quite
sophisticated but nevertheless from
these clusters we could overlay those a
data that we had from the collaboration
with Jeremy Nathan's where we had
purified P V VIP and excitatory neurons
and so they'll and and actually then we
did SST as a separate it's another
inhibitory Nora and they'll and run on
these clusters but the excitatory neuron
this you know sort of if you use the new
and market it kind of lands right in the
middle of this huge cluster so that
suggested an enormous diversity of cell
types of the excitatory neuron group so
if you take this untie sect at piece
where we just took a piece of the whole
cortex and then you randomly you know
you we know each cell that we sequence
when we put it back in its context and
ask from on dissected where did you land
well you landed like a shotgun blast
throughout the all layers because we
didn't dissect anything okay if you now
ask well where are the superficial cells
in the middle minute mid layer cells in
these clusters so superficial cells
actually map to the top of these
clusters in a middle layer sort of maps
here and deep layer sort of map here in
other words the information contained in
the methyl ohms of the cells as what
drove the separation but they physically
are different they know that their
physical location is correlated with the
methylation State okay and this is using
the gene body methylation you can get
the same thing if you just call the
upstream regulatory element methylation
depletion you get the same it's not
where quite as robust because the the
regions are smaller the genes are big
the regulatory elements are you know 100
bases or 200 base but overall you get
very similar clusters so we thought oh
that's good
now let's now
now go through the whole brain okay
slice up the brain like a baloney okay
into 18 slices and this is carried out
by my fantastic collaborator Marga
Behrens who's been involved in all these
projects who's a neurobiologist
excellent mouse and that brain anatomist
and so these we'll look at what the
slices would look like if you if you if
you annotated the regions using the
Allen Brain Alice Oh Alan Paul Alan has
devoted a lot of his resources to to the
human study of the human brain and mouse
brain and there's a wonderful atlas that
if you go to the Allen Brain now as you
can see they've done in situ
hybridisation essentially with every
gene in the mouse genome and so these
maps would actually be overlaid with in
situ hybridization so this is just a map
of one slice sliced for okay so we lyse
Margo would dissect these regions ABCDE
after you they're all they all have
interesting names for different cortical
regions for the most part here or
subcortical regions purify those we'd
carry out single-cell methylation and
what I won't talk about is eat very
interesting work from Bing ran a
long-term collaborator on looking at
open chromatin in these regions so
here's just an example of what the data
looks like so here's some cortical areas
of the brain motor cortex this
somatosensory cortex and other regions
of the cortex and these are some of the
clusters you get so this is a snapshot I
think we've done 70,000 plus cells
methyl ohms and these are here's 31,000
and these are the different clusters
that are annotated by the well-known
markers for these inhibitory neurons or
lair specific neurons etc here and
there's some clusters that are
unattended because there are some of
these sub subtypes so they might be lair
there might be other VIP subtypes this
is tis knee so these are kind of spread
a lot this this is a way of
dimensionality reduction that doesn't
necessarily maintain the relationships
between these clusters but other methods
do and so we can kind of get a snapshot
of what's going on but if we zoom in
let's just take just look at genes and
say okay if I take and we have a map we
have a website now you can take any gene
you're interested in and say okay
is that gene show hypo methylation and
so here's just a number of genes and and
their hypo methylation pattern and if
you look at the equivalent RNA seek data
it's a perfect match wherever the 8rb
gene is these clusters that show hypo
methylation will show enriched RNA and
so we can predict based on this gene
body depletion methylation where the
genes were expressed from looking at
that now if you kind of zoom into a one
particular cluster let's say here from
just one slice slice for where we're
looking at layer 5 be in that cortex all
the neurons that map the layer 5 B you
can kind of see something that's going
on you see the colors are sort of not
overlapping you see blue you see orange
you see green because these these these
slices here as I showed you there
they're a little bit thick and and so if
you if you have neurons that are
displaced by you know 100 microns
they're different from one another
so they're all layer 5 being excited to
many neurons but they're in slightly
different parts of the cortex ok and so
the information so within that cortex
you can blow that up and and ask ok all
those layer 5b neurons if you try to
separate them by our method they
actually separate so blue ones would be
the motor cortex primary motor cortex
somatosensory cortex cetera all these
the colors here match these clusters so
depending on where they are in the brain
they're all layer 5b they all lay in
layer 5b but if you're here here or here
that is sort of going down the side of
the brain they actually cluster
differently so we can tell these
differences and what genes are there
what genes are differentially methylated
in the ACA versus the motor cortex or
somatosensory cortex can be determined
by looking at the mess alone so that
they know top to bottom I already showed
you layer one two three four five and
they sort of know the side and actually
know front to back so if you look at
visual cortex versus frontal cortex you
can tell the differences so there's a
lot of information in the differentially
methylated regions and in the open
chromatin regions and these can be
combined differentially methylated
regions open chromatin reason can be
combined to call enrichment
of transcription factors Paul was
showing me some beautiful data of his
lab on doing exactly the same thing with
a taxi ik data and so we combined the
methylation data with the attack seek
data to and run a algorithm we call
reptile which was published a few years
ago to say okay these colors represent
these regions over here the AC a motor
cortex for example and you can see that
there are they're all cortical neurons
in layer 5 B but they have different
enrichments so there's a particular
transcription factor here brain 2 which
is also called palette 3 which is highly
enriched in this motor cortex region but
not at non enriched in adjacent ok
adjacent five layer 5b types okay so you
can see the enrichment let me go back to
here ok but there's no enrichment really
over in this in these some of these
clusters although they're all layer 5b
cortical neurons so there there are
different enrichments of transcription
factors that and these are well known to
sort of neural development people but
there are lots of motifs I'm just
showing you some of these enrichments
now the other interesting thing is if
you look at the inhibitory neurons I
mentioned there with these two major
classes you can see here you can
identify one class P V the other class
SS T but all the colors are overlapping
one another let's say so the the matter
where you are okay if you're an
inhibitory neuron and you're an SST type
in they all just sort of they they all
land on top of one another based on
their brain region okay and so what this
means is that that it's interesting that
you have cortical neurons where actually
I didn't describe you they're born in
the cortical region these inhibitory
neurons migrate in from into the brain
from so called ganglionic eminences and
so they're actually born somewhere else
and they actually have markers of where
they're born but you can't tell where
they like you know where they sit in the
brain it looks the same okay whether
you're in the front back top bottom they
all look the same you can tell them
apart from one another that there are
different subtypes
but those subtypes can't be
distinguished from one another based on
where they live in the brain okay and
this is actually being born out
so by the folks that are looking at the
RNA that transcriptional profiles and
the same thing that you can do with
excited Turner's you can do with
inhibitory neurons you can call
enrichments okay so you have these two
subtypes of parvalbumin inhibitory
neurons one group is enriched in this
class of transcription factors the other
group is enriched in the fast immediate
early transcription factors so circle
potentially activated and these are not
activated in this immediate order
transcript so this is based on you know
several hundred thousand differentially
methylated regions in these subtypes
right so there's a lot of differences
that you can identify then you of course
the the goal this is really you know
it's interesting to study the mouse but
to apply this to the human brain so
we've begun to do that this is just a
few thousand six thousand methyl ohms
comparing different brain regions it's
certainly more complicated being ran is
also in parallel carried out a tack seek
of these split the nuclei give them the
Bing he's carried out of taxi and we're
trying now to merge this data it's not
so easy actually to merge these
different data types even if they're the
same from the same pool nucleus because
there's there's there signatures as I
just mentioned of what's going what's
happened in the past or the development
of these neurons in the methylome that
doesn't seem to be present in what's
happening right now in the open
chromatin and so it's a little bit
tricky you get slightly different
clusters you can use this information to
call regulatory elements in the human
brain that's here so Rick young
identified these elements he calls super
enhancers clusters of enhancers they're
very interesting and many of the genes
that that Rick I had identified we can
recapitulate by looking at these very
large footprints of methylation that
occur in the in the human brain they can
be very very specific they can be
inhibitory neurons so these would be sub
subtypes so these are all inhibitory
neurons that the P V don't have this
footprint I'm sorry the the VIP don't
the P V and the SS T do you see this big
hole here so the inhibitory neuron
subclasses can be defined these would
fit into Rick's categorization when we
look at chromatin marks of super
enhancers close to some enhancers we can
easily see that in the methyl
data largely these are probably involved
in some phase transition and they're
excluding a lot of things and probably
including methyltransferases and so what
you can do that is and begin to take
those layer specific differentially
methylated regions to look at the
enrichments of jiwa snips okay
in all these genome-wide Association
studies and ask are there enrichments
for the regulatory elements that are
unique to several different subtypes so
are different layers so layer five here
for example - one no enrichment of
regulatory elements in G well snips
right next to it layer four yes layer
four regulatory elements based on the
attack seek and methylation data has
this significant enrichment so you might
want to look there and for sort of
biochemical further biochemical or
targeting studies for it these are just
the very beginnings we haven't done a
huge amount of sequencing this is only
maybe based on ten thousand cells so the
final thing I want to talk about is
ultimately we want to not only link the
cells but to the cells to their circuits
and so this is an effort that we've
again using Epogen a profiling to begin
to link the cells to who they connect to
and this is a collaboration with IDI
Callaway's lab and so Eddie and his
colleagues are doing we're using a mouse
that that I mentioned this mouse that
Jeremy Nathan's lab collected a
developed called the intact Mouse where
you have a kree that's flanked lock
sites that flank a stop here that's
removed in a Kree dependent fashion and
so what you can do is inject the virus
into for example the striatum that
carries create and then it will
retrograde move for two axon down the
axons that connects to the motor cortex
for example and that will activate a GFP
that then labels the nuclei in the motor
cortex so injects the virus and the
striatum it's picked up in the axon
terminals maps back to the cell body and
it activates the GFP so that it it it
now if inserts into the nuclear membrane
then we can fax and isolate there's
those nuclei that have been activated
and so you'll get the motor cortex
striatal projection neurons only those
motor cortex neurons that are projecting
from the to the striatum will be labeled
and you can do that many many times and
so we actually have a project that's it
involves mapping by injecting into all
these projections and be and more than
this and to these different brain
regions to then ask in those neurons
okay so these would be the clusters that
are developed of all those cortical
neurons from let's say in this case six
six injection experiments where you've
injected eight different brain regions
and so here you'll be checked this is
all motor cortex here and these were
injected in the striatum okay and then
motor cortex cells labeled and for
example up here here's the superior
colliculus these are the cells that are
labeled in the motor cortex they're
highly enriched in layer five B so if
you go back to the map here of all these
cells the cells that are labeled here or
in the layer 5b from the thalamus there
in 5b and depending on where you did the
inject you can see 5b is not labeled so
defining what cells can project the
different regions is reflected by their
methalone or potentially their
transcriptome we really haven't looked
at that and the cells are too few here
maybe you'll only get a hundred or two
hundred cells label it's been too few to
really do a tach seek in the methods
that we're currently using for a taxi
but you can get projection specific and
so the and this just shows some of these
five be enriched injections here but
what that gets you are the genes that
are different between those so all of
these are motor cortex and neurons the
ones that are labeled here that you're
looking at the methyl on we're from
superior colliculus or the somatosensory
cortex or the striatum and you can see
here the ones that for this particular
gene are depleted in methylation only in
the motor neurons that are projecting to
this from layer five beats of the
superior colliculus so you can define
projection specific genes that are
expressed and projection specific
regulatory elements in these cases and
these just show some other examples of
those and they're if you if you classify
these genes they're highly enriched in
thing
that that suggests that they are
involved in that in the differentiation
of the of the neural system so then if
you have elements that can target these
cells specifically drivers of Cree that
you wanted to ablate those cells or you
wanted to activate something in those
cells that's kind of the goal so we're
trying to link what I showed you where
upstream potential enhancers but linking
those to the genes is also a challenge
right I showed you gene body depletion
methylation upstream there's going to be
some depletion of DNA methylation but it
could be many different elements that
are depleted and so what we're doing is
trying to link those elements to
promoters and what we're doing is we've
collaborated with Jesse Dixon's allowed
to adapt the assay of proximity ligation
where you can take and cross-linked
nuclei so that two regions that for
example that we're in a loop right here
that if you cross link the the the the
protein here to the DNA and then you cut
the DNA and then you ligate it together
so called proximity ligation assay
developed by Decker and others you can
then this is the cut DNA then you ligate
it together you can bring together
sequences that are separated by a
distance presumably if this blue one is
a promoter and this is a putative
enhancers you now have some evidence of
looping and so we what we've done with
jesse is not only do that in single cell
but also capturing the methylation
profile from these so what we do is we
take this high C essentially three C
kind of assay and then put it into our
methyl on pipeline so we've captured the
DNA and along this DNA are going to be
methylation differences both in the
enhancer and presumably around the
promoter and we'll be able to capture
that so we're doing single-cell
multi-omics assay hi-c and methylation
and so that's just shown here I just
sort of throw up one of these diagrams
these are the single nuclei only let's
say 200 nuclei and we can take that and
we can reconstruct if we synthetically
put pool those 200 cells together and
look at this sort of looks like this
typical interaction map of regions where
things along that
dial up diagonally her very close to one
another and things that essentially your
mapping chromosome 3 against chromosome
3 anything off the diagonal is mapping
in a loop at a distance and so we can we
can recapitulate that from this assay we
can also recapitulate the methylation
profiles these happen to be embryonic
stem cells and so yeah this is really
interesting because when we when we
cluster based on the CH methylation or
CG methylation we can separate these
these cell types reasonably well and so
that says the methylation assay is
working the 3cs a actually does so these
are structural variants now the loops
are separating these differences between
excitatory and inhibitory neurons it it
doesn't separate them super well but it
actually separates the other cell types
pretty well and so now we're this is
only with a few hundred cells so we're
now digging in deeper because we can
sort of see hints in looking at these
excitatory when you dig down into
studying this sort of triangle ology
here of interactions you can find
enrichment for example in these between
if you compare the hi-c maps of
inhibitory and excitatory neurons you
can find regions that are actually
enriched this interaction one is
actually enriched over here and the
interaction two is enriched in
excitatory so's so we're getting some
hints even from a few hundred cells that
we can identify loops or differences
between excitatory inhibitory neurons
using this multi ohmic assay so just to
wrap up here DNA methylation profiles as
well as open chromatin profiles allow us
to classify these brain cell types yet
the cells actually have a huge amount of
information in their in their epigenome
if you will about where they live in the
brain and so they you which layer
they're in whether they're more caudal
or or whether they're there sort of on
the sides of the cortex can be so if you
gave me a cell from the mouse brain at
least from the reasons we profile I
could tell you where it lives and the
brain not exactly within that you know
exactly it's spatially but but but
pretty pretty close to that Atlas that
the brain
developed you can predict transcription
factor enrichments and ultimately we
want to understand how the different TFS
are affected in terms of their
sensitivity so when we see a difference
on methylated region in a pewter of
regulatory L we have some idea what the
code is of which factors may or may not
be affected in terms of the methylation
variation there we can identify snip
enrichment so provide some information
that I think enables helps the gos folks
to get a better idea of what cell types
may be affected we can use this
information to look at projections and
the regulatory elements that are
associated with neuronal projections and
I think these sort of multi omakase is
going to make it a little bit easier to
begin to start to associate these
different datatypes when they're from
the same nucleus and what we've we're
beginning to learn is is that actually
the information is not the same when you
cluster from the same nucleus you have
200 cells cluster based on methylation
cluster based on open chromatin our hi-c
you actually get slightly different
clusters so the information of what's
happening right now or what happened in
the past actually drives those cells to
say hey we've got something similar to
one another but different than what's
happening in the open chromatin right
now and so this work I mentioned the
plant folks the plant biology folks were
not listening on here Ryan Lister Bob
Schmidt's were the main folks and
driving that T G cow a cow katsu in my
lab and the folks that would have been
driving the Brady initio really mainly -
were for people to post doctoral
students Chung Wong Luo
who's out on the job market he's
fantastic as many offers already juju
Jiang maybe next year she's working on
mainland the visual cortex - amazing
graduate students with bioinformatics
program
Genting and Han Ching and a lot of
technical staff as you can imagine for
these kinds of projects the last thing I
mentioned about the hi-c is a
collaborator with Jesse Dixon who's a
sulky fellow so so came out of bing
Ren's lab with his PhD he started his
own lab with no postdoc and it's doing
really fantastic work and a Calloway
who's leading is the core sort of
card-carrying
scientists of this group it is me as a
developed viral viral delivery
technology for example rabies virus and
his group doing a lot of the injections
and that includes other Salk faculty
Shen and kuo-fan who have been doing
injections I mentioned Margaret is doing
all the dissections in nuclear
purification Bing is our long-term
collaborates involved pretty much in
everything that we do and he's a part of
this brain initiative that were funded
to do we have a u19 Center and Iran is a
system professor at UCSD he used to be
it's all key was in terrorist analysis
lab it's computational neuroscientists
who's really putting his major effort
into this sort of data integration
approach and our funders are here so
stop there and take any questions you
have
[Applause]
yeah yeah yeah there yeah so John's
question is how do the different the
modalities so transcriptome that's
happening right then and those cells
versus some of the other models like
methylation which may have a different
timeline in terms of its dynamics or
open chromatin very good question what
you can see with one versus the other is
kind of a challenge so if you do sort of
droplet based sequencing you kind of
just skim the surface of what you know
maybe the top 2,000 the 4,000 genes the
open chromatin you we're getting I think
we're Bing is getting maybe let's say a
thousand to ten thousand reads per cell
or something so it's sampling a subset
of the 200,000 where were more open
chromatin sites the methylation is very
deep but we can't do as many cells so
trying to overlap all the
so a challenge we're we're taking so we
now have developed an assay to measure
RNA and methylation the same nucleus
it's on paper on the borrower guide so
we're going to have a better answer for
you about the dynamics but if you just
compare so so there's a scale difference
so what you can actually see and then
then what you can overlap turns out to
be a relatively small piece and probably
the most abundant genes right most one
their transcripts so smart seek would be
if you did smart seek much deeper in
those same cells I think we'd have a I
think I'd have an answer for you is to
but there's a lot of let's say if you
look at the if you look at the number of
differentially methylations overlap that
so it's a big circle because there's a
lot of things that are have kind of
happened in the past there's a nice
paper on the bower no and molecular cell
last week from a group at the
dana-farber looking at something that
bing Ren discovered a while ago called
vestigial enhancer so you can see lots
of events cuz they look at intestinal
villi and they can see the lineage and
so they look and say oh where do these
differentially methylated regions what
are they they're open they're open but
where were they if you look back at
development they were an enhancer in our
earlier time so being called this
digital answers and because they have a
time course they can follow those things
so there's a lot of information in the
mental illness that's not from now some
of it overlaps with open chromatin and
some of that will overlap with
transcriptome but I think if I gave you
an answer it would be just the top two
thousand genes and may not be
representative of the most interesting
ones but it's a very good thing to do if
you could do deep transcriptome
sequencing on the same nuclei I think
you'd be able to get an answer about the
how certainly when you cluster them you
can get different clusters right so
there is information in those but you
know certainly for the methylome that
data can tell us where for example the
the inhibitory neurons came from and
that's information that's no longer
represented in the chart scriptum that
happened you know during the development
ontogeny of those cells
you
yeah so most of the the most so you can
see it in other tissue so if you look on
this paper he at all that we have on bio
archive for last two years it's under
it's in stuff that in principle in
nature it shows it shows accumulation in
in post mitotic must know in muscle so
many in many different you know heart
and stomach etc you'll see a little bit
of accumulation and it accumulates at a
point where the and enriched on the
bodies of transcription factors that
when you ask what they are they're the
master regulators of the genesis of that
organ so if you look at all the data
from you know the heart development
you'll find the major transcription
factors involved at heart development as
the heart matures they begin to
accumulate CH methylation over the body
of the transcription factors that
presumably and it's correlated with
silencing of those but it's it's a
fraction of the amount so it might be
ten percent of the amount of methylation
that you would see in the nor even lower
maybe five percent so but that could be
when it's bulk we're grinding it so it
could be a few cells in that it could be
it could be that it's just a very you
know sparse amount of methylation we
don't know because we haven't done
single-cell profiling of those organs
but it does accumulate in a variety of
tissues in but at a much lower level and
it identifies with with amazing accuracy
every TF you go back in the literature
you say oh that was this study in
development they showed this TF was
involved in making a kidney right it
just it maps out the master regulators
of those tissues
you want to shut them off presumably
you've finished the developer you want
to shut them down and it it may not be
directly at fault may just be some
signature we don't know the causality of
this but it's certainly a good marker
for what what was happening at in that
organ
thank you
[Applause]
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at Cornell edu